[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اني
هذا الفيروس
[موسيقى]
تقنيات بلا انسانيه هذا معنى فايب جي تقتل
[تصفيق]
ني
تظن ان الكائنات الفضائيه مازالت تزور
الارض نعم
هذا غير حقيقي
ستخرج الامه كلها الى الشوارع
ستكون
القادمه حول ما هو الواقع الذي نعيش فيه
[موسيقى]
يلا
كنت مختصا وادير عمليه استخبارات مضاده
لصالح سلاح الجو في الولايات المتحده في
ثمانيه القرن الماضي كان لدينا برنامج
طائرات مسيره في قاره كارلانك وكان حين
ذاك بالغ السريه
كنا نضم الينا المنظمات الاخباريه ووسائل
الاعلام المحليه وكنا نزرع التقارير
الاخباريه وكانوا ينسخون ورائها اذ لم
يكونوا يعرفون الحقيقه
ماذا كان مدى انتشار العمليه
كانت واسعه الانتشار وصلت الى مستوى رئيس
هيئه الاركان المشتركه ومن هناك الى مدير
المخابرات المركزيه
ثم من هناك الى البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
اتعتقد ان اكاذيبكم حول الاجسام الطائره
اضرت بثقه الجمهور بالاعلام نعم لابد ان
اقول للاسف انها فعلت عندما انتشرت القصه
الحقيقيه لاحقا خدعتهم وسائل الاعلام
ثقه الجمهور بالحكومه ايضا نعم الجمهور
طوال الوقت منذ ذلك الحين
اف يو الامريكيين في منتصف الستينيات عن
ثقتهم في ان الحكومه تفعل الصواب لقال 77
بالمئه منهم نعم لدي ثقه في الحكومه
مررنا ببيتنام وحكمته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كانت حكايه تقليديه ما يلبث الناس ان
يدركوا ان من بداخل البيت الابيض
في الثمانينيات في عهد ريجن تدنت نسبه
الامريكيين الذين يثقون بالحكومه الى 25%
الشامل
ماهر
خداع امام مجلس الامن الدولي يوم الخامس
من فبراير 2003 واليوم اشعر بندم شديد
ماشي ماشي
لقد انهار ركن اخر سواء كان ذلك مخزون
الاسلحه الكيماويه او البيولوجيه او
مختبرات الاسلحه البيولوجيه
وقالوا لي حسنا ليست لدينا اربعه مصادر
مستقله تثبت وجود عربه انتاج الاسلحه
البيولوجيه كان شخصا واحدا ثبت انه مخادع
وهو الان في سجن الماني ولم نتحدث معه
مطلقا
طول الصيفي
في محاوله عقلنه ما فعلناه لم تكن حربا
سيئه بل جيده صدام حسين
تمام حياتي حيويه
[موسيقى]
ولا
اي شيء اخر
بالاسباب مثل هل سيعاد انتخاب جونسون اذا
ما اوقف الحرب وفر من فيتنام
اشعر بان حكومه
الولايات المتحده فيما يتعلق بحاله الامن
القومي
طبقه من المحافظين الجدد برزت في الولايات
المتحده من حطام حربي فيتنام
تقوم على نصح هؤلاء السياسيين طبقه جديده
من الخبراء الفنيين في السياسه
كم يساوي
بها
نيابه عن الحكومه احيانا بمبادره مني
واحيانا لانه طلب مني ذلك
ما يقوله الناس عن الحملات التي ينظمها
يقوم جله على الخوف والتشويه سياسه كره
الطين
الجدد
الحين تقريبا
ربما عبر اوروبا عن ذلك افضل تعبير حين
قال تتصرف الامبراطوريه فتخلق واقعا مقصده
رؤوف تحديدا هو ان روما الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه في اوجه خلقت واقعا في العالم
من خلال القوه التي كانت تملكها اقتصاديا
وماليا وعسكريا
في الطريقه التي يرى الناس بها ذلك الواقع
ولكن يمكن التدخل في ذلك الواقع بطرق يتم
من خلالها تاثير على الناس بحديث يرون
انفسهم ويرى بعضهم بعضا
لماذا يسمح
الامريكيهم افتراضا ان يختاروا رفض ذلك
التدخل
الربح يجلب رغم الامن والامان يجلب لهم
مستوى معقولا من المعيشه الجيده
ببساطه ليست لديهم القدره الذهنيه للتعامل
مع ما يعنيه ان تكون امبراطوريه
اذا تتعمد كستراتيجيه سياسيه من اجل كسب
الانتخابات ان تحدث الانقسامات هائله
انقسامات بالغه الخطوره على المدى البعيد
داخل المجتمع ذاته
الحقائق الجديده التي يسعدنا لخلقها دائما
ترسم خطا فاصلا بيننا وبينهم
هم يهدمون تماثيلنا لماذا ثقبي المؤشرات
الموجوده هؤلاء يسعون للاستيلاء على هذا
البلد وهذا العالم لهذه الغايه
في داخلي نار طويل
اخشى الحياه كنت اتحدث مع صديق حول تعلم
صيد الغزال بالقوس وسلخه نسمي ذلك العيش
خارج الشبكه ان حوذا مزرعه في مكان ماء
ونعيش بتلك الطريقه
[موسيقى]
عندما تصبح الحكومات اقل استعدادا
للاستجابه لاحتياجات شعبها وتعمل باطراد
على خدمه مجموعه من المصالح الاغلبيه
العظمى من السكان بصله تتراجعوا فكره انها
قوه من اجل الخير او انها تقول الصدق
افضل طريقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا خرجت بعد حدود الظلام
مجموعات مثل حياه السوري
عندما يقول الشمس سبايسر ان عدد من الناس
جاء الى هذا التنصيب اكبر من اي تنصيب
سابق
اسمع صوتا في داخلي يقول هذه لحظه سخيفه
اخرى
من الناس في الصوره اليمنى مقارنه بالصوره
اليسرى
ده اسمه زكريا
دليلا حقيقيا كدليل الفوتوغرافي ثم نرى ما
اذا كانوا سيستمرون في الزعم بان ما لا
نراه حقيقيا يرونه بام اعينهم حقيقيا
قال لي صديق اعمل معه في مؤسسه المسحيه
فلنفع ذلك
من البالغين قالوا انهم راوا في الصوره
التي فيها عدد اقل من الناس عددا اكبر
وكانت تلك صوره تنصيب ترامب
هذا امر مذهله لانه واضح تماما وجود عدد
اكبر من الناس في تنصيب اوباما مقارنه
بتنصيب ترامب
وبدات الصوره واضحه تماما
هل قالوا ذلك
هو
قوله
امامه حقيقي
مناره
[موسيقى]
تحت السرير
لحظه تقول
ولكني رايتك تغادر
فيقول لكن ما تصدقين
لما يمكن ان يعتبر مرحله ماساويه جدا
[موسيقى]
ثم خرج من يقول هناك حقائق وحقائق بليله
عندما تكون مجرد اباطيل وافتراءات هو
مفسده كبيره
تاريخيا
صوره بسيطه
نقاشين
1984 حيث يتم تعذيبه ونستون في الروايه من
قبل ممثلين عن الاخ الكبير الذي يسعى
لحمله على الاعتقاد بان اثنين زائد اثنين
[موسيقى]
زائد اثنين
من ناحيه اخرى يمكنك ان تتدخل لتحمل الناس
على الاعتقاد باشياء محدده او على التصرف
بطرق محدده وتاثير عليهم حتى يبدلوا او
يغيروا الواقع الذي فيه يعيشون
[موسيقى]
يكذبون اكثر هذه الايام لصياغه واقع زائف
اظن الموضوع الاعمق ليس كون الكذب اكثر
رواجا اعتقد انه اكثر رواجا لكن سهوله
التصديق الاشياء الزائفه باتت اكثر رواجا
[تصفيق]
هنا نصل الى زمن اوباما وترامب نجد ان اقل
من 15 بالمئه من الامريكيين يقولون انهم
يثقون بالحكومه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تقول النظام ضدكم ولكني في
خدمتكم الى مستقبل الزاهر
باريس
باعتبارها دوله عميقه
لم يعد هناك
تسلمي لي يا اسبانيا
عديده ولم نعد نصدقهم
كيف وصلت الامور الى هذا الحد
وتخطوه وكذبه كذبه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لكنهم يزداون لا يمكنك الحديث بالمنطق
معهم يكذبون في وجهك ويعرفون انهم يكذبون
في وجهك كلهم بحاجه فقط الى ان يخرسوا
اه اه
يمكن ان يتحول هذا الى سلاح قد يتلاعب به
القاده لانهم اذا ادركوا انصارهم لن
يحاسبوهم ولا عواقب وخيمه الانتخابيه
فسيصبح الكذب بنسبه لهم امرا معقودا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تتحدث عن الحقائق البديله والوقائع
البديله وبتمان اعيش في عصر ما بعد
الحقيقه فانما يحدث في الواقع هو تسييس
للحقيقه
لقد رجع ذلك لدرجه ان الامور التي كانت
تعتبر خارجه عن الحدود باتت الان تعتبر
حقيقه لان ثمه وسائل اعلام ومواقع تواصل
اجتماعي يمكن ان تعزز ذلك
يحصل على قراءه صادقه لما يجري فعلا
الافراد في الشارع مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي والناس بما لديهم من هواتف
خلويه مجازه بكاميره فيديو بامكان التقاط
فيديو اينما ذهبنا وان نرفعها عبر النت ثم
تنتشر
الكثير من السرديات والرسائل يدفع بها عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي من السهل توليد
معلومات مضلله ونظريات مؤامره واخبار
كاذبه وتسريبها الى قطاع كبير من السكان
[موسيقى]
ترامب استخدم المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لنشر المعلومات المظلله على مستوى غير
مسبوق
الناس من شعور الامن من خلال خلقه اعداء
لا وجود لهم سوى في اذهان الناس
الجديده الحرب السياسيه
كتاب
مؤسسات التعليم العالي لا تثق بالجامعات
لا تثق بالاساتذه لا تثق بالعلماء
الى ايطاليا ثم الولايات المتحده قالت
رامبو البارزه في المحيط الاعلامي للحزب
الجمهوري ان ذلك لن يكون
[موسيقى]
كانت مناوره هائله لاثاره الخوف عندما
يكون لدينا فايروس معدل الوفاه بسببه سته
من عشره في المئه فان معدل النجاه منه
يزيد عن 99 في المئه
لقد فتحنا وحده طبيه جديده للاستجابه
للحالات الشديده الاخيره
ساذهب الى المستشفى وتموت بسبب زائده
المنفجره او جلطه وسواء فحصت ام لا قد
يكتبون على شهاده وفاتك ان السبب كوميدي
تماما لان كل واحد من المرضى غالبا ثبتت
اصابته
والفحوصات معطوبه
هو سبب الوفاه حتى عندما كان السبب
الحقيقي اصابه باطلاق نار
[موسيقى]
هي الشركات ذاتها التي جلبت لنا ازمه
الادمان فلماذا نفق بها
انت تتعامل مع شركات مرضت على الاجرام
24 24
الذي حدث هو
اثنتين كلتاهما تشككان في مزاعم المعارف
التقليديه الحركه المناهضه
[موسيقى]
ما ان بدا فيديو جوديتس بلندمك يجذب
الانتباه في الدوائر اليسريه واليمنيه على
حد سواء حتى برزت الفكره التي تقول ان كل
ما يمكننا الاتفاق عليه هو انه ينبغي الا
نصدق اي شيء تقوله الحكومه
تشكل خطرا شخصيا على رئاسه فحدث ما
شاهدناه منه
المرحله انتشرت فيديوهات كثيره
لاناس في المحلات او المطاعم من انصار
ترامب كانوا يتميزون ايضا اذا طلب منهم
ارتداء الكيمامات
هناك جزء غير عقلاني في النفسيه البشريه
وهو امر يمكنك تتبعه الى الهواسبره في
القرن السابع عشر
يوتيوب يوتيوب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ترموز لطلبه وجدت نظريته مؤامره حول
الجوائح ففي اوروبا منتصف القرن الرابع
عشر وقع طاعون عرف باسم الموت الاسود فتك
بنسبه كبيره لسكان اوروبا
تعليمه في الاساس من قبل وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه من اجل نزع الصدقيه عن من كانوا
يقولون ان هي هيئه تحقيق التي حققت في
اغتيال عمي كانت مجنونه ولا ينبغي يعني
اسطوانه الفجر
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي العالمي و مليارديرته دافوس
وجوجل وابل وامازون التكنولوجيا
بدء الجائحه
اعتقد اننا بحاجه
امام مجلس الشيوخ لن اساله عن رؤيته بعيده
المدى لحقن الجميع باللقاح فواضح ان الامر
لا يتعلق بكل 19
لقد تفاخر بالجيتس بان شركته سوف تراقب كل
كائن بشري على وجه المعموره على مدى 24
ساعه في اليوم وهم يتعاقبوننا من داخل
بيوتهم الناس ان اليكسا تعمل لصالح وهذا
غير صحيح بل انت الذي تعمل لصالحها تخبرها
باسرارك وتزودها ببياناتك وفي نهايه
المطاف سيكونون قادرين على معاقبهم وهم
يفعلون ذلك الان
انهم يطلقون حركه التحول من خلال تلك
المطاعيم يحاولون الناس الى الالات ليدمن
على جوجل كلاود وبذلك يمكن ان نقضي وراءنا
سيطره نظام التصنيف الاجتماعي الصيني
[موسيقى]
اجتماعيا سالب يقال ان المطعم تحتوي على
ما يسمى هيدروجين وهو برمجه
ناروتو تقنيه داخل هذه اللقاحات من اجل
ناشولات مع تكنولوجيات الاخرى وبذلك يتم
تحويل التجربه البشريه الى ما يمكن دمجه
داخل رؤيه المتحوله بشريه بتقنيه
او اي شيء يمكن ان يؤثر على تركيباتنا
الوراثيه كائنات بشريه
مغامره فقط ولكن ايضا من يشرون عليك
بعشرات المراجع التي تؤكد ذلك النوع من
الروس
لازم
تلقي اي مطاعم وثلث من يخدمون في القطاعات
الاخرى يرفضون التطعيم نعم ههه
بانهم شيطان وهذا ما تدركه عندما تقرا ما
هو مكتوب عنهم ذلك هو اخر اختيار للشيطان
فهو في الواقع من يحكم الكوكب
عندما
[موسيقى]
يبقى في الحقيقه الكثير من ما يمكن ان
يناقش
لا اقول ان بعض النظري
بل بعضه كذلك بالفعل ولكن معظمه يقوم على
الجهل والخوف وحتى اللامبالاه وذلك هو
اكبر العوامل على الاطلاق
وذلك من صنع السياسيين غير مهذبين يعرفون
انه باطل ولكنهم يرون كم الناس الذين
يعتقدون به ويسعون للحصول على اصوات هؤلاء
الناس
[تصفيق]
فرانك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لين
كل من في البلد يعرفون ان ترامب فاز في
هذه الانتخابات والعالم كله يعرف واذا ما
انتزع الحريه من صوتنا فاقرا على البلد
السلام
من اجل عافيتي هذا البلد والاباء المؤسسين
اليسار يسعى لتمزيقنا ولن نسمح بذلك
اخبارك
كل الناس يحبون ترامب يسعون لاسكاتنا وهذا
لا يحدث شاهد كم من الناس هنا بيض لا يملك
ان يجمع ملء المراهقات لامريكا
لو كنت تعرف ولو القليله من العبريه فان
الرقم 6 هو خط مستقيم اعلى واسفل اذا وضعت
ثلاثه منها يكون لديك سته سته سته وتلك
علامات الوحش
شعار بيد يحتوي على ثلاثه خطوط حمر
مستقيمه ليست الحرف اي بل 666 بالعبريه
الكتاب المقدس كتب بالعبريه هناك علاقه
انا اقول بالتاكيد هناك علاقه
الادله كثيره على الاحتلال على نطاق
الواسع في الانتخابات عبر الالات الاقتراع
وعندما ادرك انه يحصل على اصواتا تتفاوق
على الاحتلال الذي خططوا له راحوا في
منتصف الليل يملؤون صادقا الاقتراح
شقق
الانتخابات
شوكو
لا
والقي بها في القمامه
غير حقيقي
وانا وانا
تعاقب بالسجن خمس سنوات اما اذا تامرتا
الحد الادنى عشر سنين
مباشر
لا دليل
الكثير من علماء السياسه والانتخابات
نظروا في هذا الامر مطولا ولا شيء من هذا
القبيله
سرق انتخابات 2020 يصدقها 63% من
الجمهوريين داخل الولايات المتحده
الانتخابات في محاوله منهم لعكس النتائج
وبذلك ساره واحد من بين حزين سياسيين فقط
لدينا فقد استولى عليه الى حد كبير مجموعه
من الناس الذين يشهرون عدم الثقه كالسلاح
بما يمكن ان يعدك
وراء السياره
[تصفيق]
اكشن المانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ربما هكذا ستموت الديمقراطيه سننتهي الى
خلاف على نمط الحقيقه بلا حل ودون الاتفاق
على حقيقه واحده بما يسمح بالحكم الجماعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ديمقراطيه اذا كان شعبك او اغلبيته لا تثق
بحكومته سؤال ضخم يعتقد كثير علماء
السياسه
[تصفيق]
اذا استمر هذا اعتقد اننا سنشهد مزيدا من
الفوضى ومزيدا من التعطيل وربما مزيدا من
العرض ايضا
[موسيقى]
خلال ال 10 سنين او 20 القادمه حول تفسير
الحقائق وانما حول اي واقع ذلك الذي نعيش
فيه واظن في هذه اللحظه لا يوجد ما يحاول
تغيير راي احد حول كيف نفسر الواقع فنحن
في حرب حول ما هي ذلك الوقت
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
كان طوله حوالي اربعه اقدام وتسعه وكان
لديه ادوات شفط على اصابعه انه خائف موجود
في هذا المجتمع الغريب في كوكب غريب تم
اسره ولا يعرف ماذا نحن انه خائف منا
لكننا عملناهم معامله حسنه
واخيرا قال طالب في الجيش اتعلمون اظنني
قد اتمكن
من تعليمه اللغه الانجليزيه
ويتحدث عن كائنات فضائيه هناك عرقيه يمكن
ان تكون مؤذيه
كان الرئيس
الامم المتحده
ايه اكيد
تزور الارض
نعم
لك في نشر المعلومات
نعم بالتاكيد
من يقولون هذا لم يعملوا يوما في
الاستخبارات او في الحكومه ولم يكن لديهم
تصريح امني لم اذهب الى هناك بشكل عشوائي
واصبح منشقا وانشر المعلومات المضلله لكل
من يخطر ببالي كانت هناك غايه محدده عمليه
نسميها عمليه الاستخبارات المضاده وانتم
تسمونها معلومات مضلله اتفهم من يقولون
كيف نصدقك وانت تنشر معلومات مضلله فعل
ذلك لاني امرت ان افعل ذلك
[ضحك]
والمضحك انه تعلم الانجليزيه اليس كذلك
اشياء مختلفه في العالم الذين نعيش فيه
يستحيل تفسيرها بالكامل وتظل عصيه على
الفهم وهذا ما يجعله رائعا جدا لا عجب اي
ينحرف الناس قليلا من وقت الى اخر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]